um do we do we have that indeed
commercial that commercial was
that that was some that was
it was uh i mean
we just gotta watch commercial show it
to me let's see it do you have it luke i
no i don't have it
oh we got music though
you can just help mute the music
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah muted media made it yeah all right
so you guys got the vibe it's like this
like
we hope the ones starting out get jobs
we help the ones
starting over get jobs we help the ones
thinking about today
get jobs we hope the ones thinking about
tomorrow get jobs
okay we helped the hell bent get jobs
we helped the determined get jobs
brother salary slider
we help the qualified get jobs
we help the hopeful get okay okay
the beginners the experienced
and we help the ready get jobs
[Music]
indeed we help people get first of all
what a dumb ass slogan
we help people get jobs first of all
they don't
if anyone's ever used bro have you ever
used indeed
no but clearly people do if they have
enough money to do a [ __ ] super bowl
commercial bro
stop it maybe indeed like five years ago
kind of worked okay maybe
the i don't know the funniest [ __ ] to me
was during a super bowl
after a [ __ ] pandemic where
unemployment is pretty brutal
they're just gonna [ __ ] spit in
people's faces and be like
hey we know you're on the couch right
now needing a job
we can help you get that job it's just
like i don't know
i feel like you think that's bad i think
it's kind of an [ __ ] move
i mean why what if if their thing is
like we it would
that would be an [ __ ] move if they
didn't help at all but if you can use it
to find a job how is that an [ __ ]
thing
i think it's an [ __ ] thing because
it's like that could be the one day
you're just trying to enjoy
you might be with some family or
something they're like hey we just want
to remind you
you might be unemployed right now your
family's like
yeah exactly exactly yeah that
commercial comes on and they're like
oh dad have you been on indeed lately
he's like
yeah every [ __ ] day bro
the funniest [ __ ] to me was the salary
slider where he just goes from 55 to 75.
like let me just see
like let me just see what's out there
wait so that's all it takes that's all
it takes to make more money i can just
slide yeah just slide your salary that's
all you do
i love yeah i love an 80k salary then
yeah
that's the part that's [ __ ] dick as
well
oh you know what i don't feel like
making this amount of money anymore i
want to make more and you just
push to the right ah yes that's what i
would like
yeah that's fair i mean yeah i guess it
is maybe it's dick because there just
aren't jobs available yeah so that's why
i think it's [ __ ]
giving people hope with this
inspirational commercial where it's like
we help
everyone get a job yeah you can get a
job and here's a job for you and here's
steve jobs
[Music]
and then you get on there you put all
this information on indeed and they're
like all right so we got a bunch of user
information and we it's like
yeah just selling your [ __ ] sell your
info
and here's zero jobs he's like
he's like actually i'd like to make yeah
i'd like to make 80 or 90k
yeah zero results oh okay how about
40. zero results all right
yeah what what you know 39
38.
yeah okay i see i see what you're saying
now yeah it's it's not it's
it's not nice and uh but i think the
other funny part is they'll just get
everybody on there
and sell that data and they're just
making money
off of people who can't make money right
now
yeah that's yeah that's fair although
yeah who knows though they i mean
they maybe they paid more for that super
bowl ad
no they probably it probably is worth it
for them yes
yeah you're talking about how much sorry
go ahead
no no we were talking about how much
super bowl ads cost
i think the average is 5 million for a
super bowl ad
jeez and what was it like ian from sea
geek tweeted 20 000 or 20 million people
watch the super bowl
or something like that yeah right yeah
they're watching um
how many ads do you think on average
they're watching over the course of the
super bowl
probably like 20 yeah something like
that
at least i feel like it's like between
three and five for every break
yeah and so his tweet was mr mr beast
gets 20 million views at least per video
or something like that i know it's like
not really a comparison but if you think
about
watching 20 mr beast videos and him
having the same amount of reach
as someone's as all of america the whole
world sitting through the entire super
bowl that's pretty wild
because it's the most watched thing in
the planet isn't it it is
yeah that's pretty crazy man
yeah pretty pretty wild that everybody
tunes in to
watch a bunch of guys chase after a ball
[ __ ] sucks um
okay let's get it let's um we've watched
a robin hood commercial
oh yeah let's do that let's do that
cue this [ __ ] up i was dying laughing i
could not believe this [ __ ]
what a oh what a
title is there music do they even start
we are all investors they didn't even
allow
likes or dislikes scroll down you can
turn that off well you know is this
is this like is this like like like like
comments or yeah
yeah you're right disabled
we are all investors start playing it
with sound just to see if there's music
and if they're
yeah it's it's a really [ __ ] lame
here i'll do the i'll i'll do the fake
ass piano ready yeah
all right woman petting a dog
guy running up a mountain we have
someone oh wait i forget is there a
voiceover
on mute it for a sec [ __ ] is their
voiceover
there is damn it yeah damn it we
we gotta watch this in the bone zone
brothers okay okay okay we will it's
dude what ha
what what happens though oh they're
basically it's like same sort of thing
yeah it's like we help everyone invest
oh no matter who you are you could work
at a daycare you could
i said this way too late afterward and i
deleted it but like
i wouldn't be surprised if people burned
down indeed
and robin hood uh
like because of those commercials i'd be
so [ __ ] pissed
if i was like even remotely close to
either
like it just seemed like they were
preying on people who
were down you know what i mean like it
just felt like oh are you jobless during
the super bowl
we'll help you you know what i mean it's
like that person's been trying to get a
job for a year you [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah yeah okay that's fair you
know and robin hood has that they buy
that commercial
they probably bought it way in advance
but given everything they just did
how do they not think we should probably
pull out
[Laughter]
because someone along the way was like
dude we spent 5 million on this
we're not pulling out pull out game
terrible by robin hood
it's like no matter how many people we
[ __ ] two weeks ago
yeah we can still [ __ ] some more yeah
this super bowl commercial yeah
you know the robin hood way we don't
know
there are still some people that don't
have money to lose
and we can help them lose it yeah
you know with all the buzz about
uh gamestop and everything going on
there's a large percentage of americans
in nursing homes that have access
to cellular devices and have liquid cash
to trade
they just aren't aware so we want to be
targeting those with mild dementia
[Music]
[Laughter]
and stay-at-home grandparents that are
being taken care of by their
immediate family yeah
have you ever thought about yellowing
your bar mitzvah money
into a stupid stock
no that's [ __ ] gen z
yeah i know there's that's what i'm
saying they're targeting targeting
everyone people with dementia
gen z who you know their very first
savings that's what they're supposed to
put towards college or
whatever entrepreneurial endeavor no
yolo that into [ __ ] uh you know
can you imagine you imagine some
desperate ass like
uh commercial targeted old people like
by robin hood and just like starts with
war footage you've seen
all what you've seen all parts of
america through
history but what was the one thing that
stood the test of time
that created success the stock market
stop trading corn and disney and trade
with with real stocks that net you real
earnings look at
look at history look at the stock market
now compared to where it was 100 years
ago
stocks only go up and you still got five
years left
so what are you waiting for clayton
take the remainder of your social
security and throw it in the game stop
today we'll give you a free share
because that's the american way helping
your fellow man
robin hood we need to meet in the middle
so much meat in the middle
oh damn gay burger nice gay burger
hell yeah beef me up daddy america's so
sus always trying to meet in the middle
those weird commercials dude about
meeting in the middle and then
by a jeep
what is that even in reference to it's
like you know
just what is meeting in the middle the
last size just like the last year
and and how polarizing and
how crazy just the world got and
okay [ __ ] they're trying to talk
about uniting people who stormed the
capital
and you know other people protesting
against let's put our differences aside
yeah and buy a [ __ ] jeep for this
jeep that we all love
yeah i kind of like someone said
budweiser
not bud light but budweiser didn't for
the first time
in 20 years or something like that
didn't have a super bowl ad
oh yeah i think it was luke that was
saying that actually yeah yeah well you
know because if
just how turbulent the year has been
they're like we're just gonna stay out
we're not gonna take any we're just
gonna stay out of it
and we're not i think this is not a year
to market our product
honestly i don't think anyone needs any
more marketing
this year it's been a tough year
and that's why mr clean is the best
cleaning supply for your counters
people believe mr clean
symbolizes
i'm sorry i'm just thinking about
[ __ ] mr clean being co-opted as like
a
white supremacy icon
just like a bald white guy in mainstream
media
[Laughter]
oh wait didn't they didn't they change
mr clean
i thought they i thought they had a no
they didn't
i thought there was like he got hair
plugs you got hair plugs yeah
it's got fabio hair now yeah they just
just long ass sick flow yeah
mr clean up i mean isn't there some
conspiracy like mr clean is gay
why because of the earring okay what's
wrong with one earring
i don't know man huh i'm not saying
there's anything wrong with it
i thought that was like some conspiracy
back in the day
dude i'd be sick if he had just like
insane hockey hair
so you're saying would be sick if he was
gay
andy was gay would be sick if he had
dope hair andy was gay
you